to you the the basic characteristics of
human nature such that we'll be okay if
the incentives are okay
we'll we'll do we'll do pretty good
I'm worried about the asymmetries that
you know it's easier to break things
than to fix them it's easier to
to
[Music]
um
uh light a fire than to put it out and
uh
I do worry that you know as technology
gets more and more powerful it becomes
easier for the minority who wants to
screw things up to effectively screw
things up for everybody right so it's
easier it's like it
a thousand years ago it was simply
impossible for one person to
derange the lives of millions much less
billions
now that's getting to be possible
so on the assumption that we're always
going to have a sufficient number of
crazy individuals or or
malevolent individuals it's it's uh
that is we have to figure out that
asymmetry somehow and so there's some
cautious exploration of emergent
technology that we need to get
our our head screwed on straight about
so like so gain a function research like
just how much do we want to democratize
uh you know all the relevant
Technologies there you know do we want
really you really want to give everyone
the ability to order nucleotides in the
mail and and give them the blueprints
for viruses online because of you know
you're a free speech absolutist and you
think all PDFs need to be
uh you know exportable everywhere
um
so much more so this is where yeah so
there are limits to
many people are confused about my take
on Free Speech because I've come down on
on
the unpopular side of some of these
questions but
it's been my overriding concern is that
in in many cases I'm worried about the
free speech of
the individual businesses or individual
platforms or individual you know media
people
to decide that they don't want to be
associated with certain things right so
like if if you own Twitter I think you
should be able to kick off the not so
you don't want to be associated with
because it's your platform you own it
right that's your free speech right
that's the side of my free speech
concern for Twitter right it's not that
every Nazi has the right to to be to
algorithmic speech on Twitter I think if
you own Twitter you should be you or the
you know whether it's just Elon or you
know in the world where it wasn't Elon
just the people who own Twitter the the
and the board and the shareholders and
the employees
these people need to just can should be
free to decide what they want to promote
or not they're public I view them as
Publishers more you know more than as as
Platforms in the end and
um that has other implications
but I do worry about this problem of
misinformation and
algorithmically and otherwise you know
supercharged misinformation
and
I think
I do think we have we're at a bottleneck
now I mean I guess it could be the
hubris of every present generation to
think that their moment is especially
important but I do think with the
emergence of these Technologies
or some kind of bottleneck where we
really have to figure out how to get
this right and if we do get this right
if we figure out how to not drive
ourselves Crazy by giving people access
to all the all possible information and
misinformation at all times
I think yeah we could there's no limit
to how
happily we could collaborate with
billions of creative fulfilled people
you know it's just and trillions of uh
robots some of them sex robots but
that's another robots that have are
running the right algorithm whatever
that algorithm is whatever you need in
your life to make you happy so I'm
um I was the first time we talked is one
of the huge honors of my life I've been
a fan of yours for a long time the few
times you were respectful but critical
to me means the world and thank you so
much for helping
um helping me and caring enough and
caring enough about the world and for
everything you do but I should say that
the few of us that try to put love in
the world on Twitter miss you on Twitter
but yes enjoy yourselves
don't don't break anything else have a
good party without me thanks so much uh
very very happy to do this thanks thanks
for the invitation thank you great to
see you again